hey guys now this is the third video of
the body transformation from skinny to
muscle and in this video I'm gonna share
my nutritional plan with you my diet
plan that helped me to gain over 15
kilos in just 10 weeks let's not waste
any more time let's get to it made
mistakes but mistakes make you strong
not just before we get into it you need
to know that your diet plan or your
nutritional plan is a lot more important
than you think it is a lot of people
workout like crazy at the gym but then
they eat the wrong kind of food and then
they wonder why they can't seem to gain
any muscle if you don't have a good
nutritional plan then you're planning to
fail so with that in mind let me give
you my nutritional plan that's
definitely gonna help you out let's
start with number one
first you got to eat a lot more you
might say well Daniel I eat a lot of
food well it's not enough if you're not
gaining the weight you got to eat more
than or at least 3,500 calories a day I
almost doubled the amount of food that I
ate for example I used to eat one slice
whole-wheat bread with tomato two eggs
and my weight was at 74 kilograms now I
ate two slices with four or five eggs
sometimes Ana fruits
second you need a lot more
nutrient-dense and healthy carbs like
whole wheat pasta brown rice whole wheat
bread potatoes and sweet potatoes and
oatmeal man I ate so much oatmeal
[Music]
number three is white protein now of
course you don't need to use this you
can just go natural but I would suggest
this because it really will help your
muscles to grow faster use good quality
whey protein that will give your muscles
what they need to grow bigger
I used muscle tech Nitra check and I
will add it for you in the video
description down below if you want to
check it out number four you got to eat
more lean meat and fish beef chicken
fish and especially eggs will give you
the protein you need I ate a lot of X
because they are affordable and it's
high-quality protein beef is also great
because it has all the essential amino
acids and creating your body wants now
if you're a vegetarian you can also get
really good protein from vegetables and
that takes us to the next point
even if you're not a vegetarian you'll
still need good vegetables in your diet
I ate mostly green vegetables to gain
muscle like spinach and broccoli and
then you will also need a healthy fats
for your overall health and strength I
got most of mine from healthy Whole
Foods like beef dairy products fatty
fish olive oil nuts and avocados now how
many times should you eat in a day or
the best is six three main meals and
then three snacks in between now with
this in mind let me show you what and
how much I normally eat in a day now
that I'm 90 kilos for breakfast I
normally eat out so I use 8 tablespoons
of oats one medium banana one handful
mixed nuts and 250 milliliters whole
milk and one scoop whey protein and then
after two and a half to three hours it's
snack time and I take a protein shake
250 milliliters milk one scoop whey
protein one medium banana and three
strawberries and then for lunch egg on
toast two slices whole wheat bread six
slices of tomato a half avocado and four
large eggs and then later for snack
protein shake again 250 milliliters of
milk one big scoop whey protein one
medium banana one cup of oatmeal so I
add some carbs and then one tablespoon
of peanut butter and then for dinner two
cups whole wheat pasta or brown rice and
I use 300 grams of chicken or beef or
fish and then 150 grams of vegetables
like broccoli or spinach and then a bit
later another snack which is 250
milliliters of milk to fruits a handful
mixed nuts and one scoop of whey protein
now this is my basic meal plan every day
it changes of course here and there when
I get too tired of eating the same thing
over and over but it gives you a rough
estimate or an idea of how much I eat
and what type of food I eat so it's
always between 3,600 to 4,000 calories a
day now if you workout and eat
consistently the right way you
well gain the muscle that you want just
some last advice before you take this on
get your head right first because the
huge problem most people have is not
with the workout routine the diet plan
or a full of these things the biggest
problem is what's going on in your head
don't worry about what people think when
you go to the gym and you're scared that
they're gonna think you're too skinny or
that you're doing things wrong or get
your head in the game keep your eyes on
the goal that you want to reach how much
weight how much muscle do you want to
gain and go for it
don't wish for a better body work for it
alright guys I'll see you in the next
video Cheers